Don't underestimate the significance of the birth control pill.
It's like the hydrogen bomb or the or the computer chip.
It's a world revolutionary technology and for all we know it might do us in,
you know,
I mean in the West,
the birth rate is far below replacement and you know,
that's as a,
has a multigenerational strategy.
That's just,
that's an absolute dead end.
And of course,
no one can talk about that because,
well,
for,
for obvious the obvious reasons of egalitarianism and diversity and all that,
but the declining birth rate and the West is really,
I would say a,
a catastrophe.
I don't have to be one of those people that you think the planet has too many
people on it,
you know,
so,
um.